up until now we have been studying the
motion of point-like objects in this
module we are going to consider the
motion of extended objects specifically
objects that are rigid bodies by rigid
we mean that the distance between any
two points on the object always say is
the same in other words the shape of a
rigid body does not change or deform
there is a useful relation known as
shawls theorem that states that the
general arbitrarily complicated
displacement of a rigid body can be
broken up into two parts first the
translational motion of its center of
mass and second a pure rotation of the
object about its center of mass we
already know how to analyze the center
of mass translational motion through our
study of point-like objects this week we
will consider the rotational motion of
rigid bodies once again distinguishing
between kinematics a geometric
description of the motion and dynamics
the underlying cause of changes in the
rotational motion on a microscopic level
we can think of an extended rigid body
as made up of a very large number of
small point like pieces all attached
together for rotation about a fixed axis
through the center of mass each little
piece will move in a circle about the
rotational axis the radius of the circle
will vary depending upon where in the
object that particular piece sits
however because all of these small
pieces are moving collectively as part
of a single rigid body they will all
have the same angular velocity and
angular acceleration at any given
instant this gives us a way to specify
the kinematics or geometrical
description of rotational motion using
the vector quantities of angular
velocity and angular acceleration we
will also consider the dynamics of
rotational motion we will see that an
applied external force is able to change
the rotational motion of a rigid body
depending upon exactly where on the body
the force is applied this leads directly
to the concept of torque a vector
quantity that represents a sort of
rotational force finally we will see
that we can link the kinematics and
of rotation of motion through a
rotational equation of motion analogous
to the role that Newton's second law
plays for translational motion this
relation states that the angular
acceleration is proportional to the
applied torque and also depends upon how
the mass of the object is distributed